[Music]
have you guys heard of a little chain
called Starbucks yes
all right well starbucks sells coffee
and recently thank you during the
protests people wanted that we're
working at Starbucks wanted to support
black lives matter so they would have
their pins they were like wearing some
like black lives matter stuff and
Starbucks said no and then Twitter found
out they said I don't want to be
involved they said we don't yeah we
don't want to do any politics religious
views any sort of we don't want to get
involved at all like and they don't
really allow employees to wear their
personal clothes anyway yeah so they
were like yeah let's not do that then
Twitter found out and the rest of social
media and they were like oh hell no
Starbucks and so they were like we're
boycotting Starbucks and Starbucks was
like oh no no no no no no no no not only
we're gonna let our buddies wear myself
cuz we're if you wear black face too if
they want no not that take their coffee
black but they are gonna be releasing
their own black lives matter merch oh so
you can feel free to still they pledged
$1,000,000 to organizations that promote
racial equity and more inclusive in just
communities now Starbucks has been known
to be very like progressive and they use
sustainable things and they they like
pushing for war and stuff and like I
don't think so yeah you know we're
supporting refugees they were gonna like
a hire a bunch of refugees because like
during the refugee crisis if you buy
their bottled water it goes to like like
starving kids in Africa or some [ __ ] but
they're starving they don't need water
Sam that's beautiful man so why do you
say like so like deep because my tummy
hurts ah you know what I love is when I
see Obama and Hillary talking about
black lives matter but then Libya right
now has open slave trading you can buy a
black slave for $200 but well when
Gaddafi was in charge who they removed
that was illegal and so whenever they do
that [ __ ] I'm like bro the same it is
crazy out there no one's talking about
that's it no they don't but we're
talking about Starbuck yeah
yeah I don't know like silence what is
the coffee's easily [ __ ] well know it or
is the coffee
I don't like you don't even ever drink
coffee huh you just literally said you
don't start when you guys invited me
here you guys said you talked about your
opinion nice would they sell lemonade
what do you think about their lemonade
is amazing what do you really repent is
so Starbucks what a minute
real er opinion about all their pain
music okay yeah no yeah no so this is a
real news real or opinions what's your
real opinion about lemonade go for it
yeah oh wow not indifferent
you gotta get the Tazo shaken iced tea
lemon have you tried the refreshers
though serious question is the pretty
good question yeah they're really good
first of all as a food club they do the
berry hibiscus but the way that they're
made its patented they extract the
caffeine from green coffee beans to
their young coffee beans and they're not
roasted they extract the caffeine and it
gives you a better caffeinated high than
the non jittery caffeine high then
coffee in the afternoon what green tea
it doesn't even come close to Jim B in
fact [ __ ] Starbucks because Jimmy's
better than you because you should go to
Jimmy thank you this you're not gonna
find anyone with black faces no it's not
allowed no corporately if we don't even
know if Starbucks allows it or not we
think that they might actually yeah we
don't know if they do but we know for a
fact Jimmy does it that's right and
that's a good corporate structure yes
yeah originally they were thinking that
that clothing my incite violence
what does not got backlash to oh so then
well I get their point because they have
racist people going there they have
people that are on other sides that are
like I don't want to buy your coffee
that's doing this so for as a company
it's one I feel like if your company
take a stand on something yeah if you
want to but it's so it's dangerous right
because like you have the protests in
downtown right and everyone's there all
sites and Tifa [ __ ] cops
protesters whatever they get thirsty and
end up putting on when they're going
like this to the cops
[ __ ] you cops but then when you're
inside Starbucks you're next to a cop
and he's thirsty then you're thirsty
they don't want to side with anyone
because now they could do it could be a
fight or something it breaks down and
starts oh they're just trying to hydrate
people I'm always do you mean by auntie
fuh I only heard that there's protestors
who also are rioters and then there's
cops that's all I heard because there is
no third tertiary I know there might be
there too sure that's not what I heard
before she before share you cuz i watch
that mainstream media sure and they tell
me what's up all-time table tertiary
yeah there might be four she area five
series yeah they did catch all that
backlash from people when they were like
we're gonna stop putting christmas
decorations on our cups yeah that wasn't
so people were like right that's the
side they'll get mad of them wearing
about yes exactly
so well then so workers we're telling
BuzzFeed that the company hands out
buttons and it's higher celebrating
LGBTQ rights in marriage equality so why
not mmm why couldn't they do that why
only LGBTQ well it's Pride Month yeah
but I mean if there's way more letters I
think then oh right right right yeah so
I'm just saying yeah I think I get them
saying like don't worry the shirts
because they have to wear company attire
but if they had pins and stuff I think I
was probably fine yeah until the shirts
arrived employees can wear pins or
shirts to show support but then after
they're come out with their own shirts
but what if you like making coffee in a
pen falls off and foster to coffee
that's dangerous and that's
disrespectful to pen they should have
written though instead of saying it's
because it's gonna incite violence oh
that my father took her the restaurant
you care was really yeah you can't you
don't your ring falling off into
someone's mashed potatoes
how come Starbucks pivoted so fast it's
almost like they had a financial
incentive but maybe I'm not well they in
their defense they were they were
pledging money in the very beginning of
the protests like before any of this
they just didn't want their employees
wearing it because they were saying like
in might incite violence they didn't
want their employees in danger by the
way that's better than the [ __ ] we're
just gonna hash tag something over a
black screen and like with with white
text and all this [ __ ] yeah but then
it's just yeah so now they're like oh
wait you're gonna break ha wait wait no
we can do it then but we'll put out our
own shirts because they still don't want
employees wear their own personal stuff
usually
hmmm as what I got from the article dude
they should have a [ __ ] piece of
March that's just red lines all over it
black shirt with red lines because of
redlining oh right what's that mean you
don't know about because they're monies
I just want to know for the guys they
know what's right line I thought that's
like pushing your engine to the max oh
it's like serious [ __ ] dude
what is that it's what I don't think it
has to do with coffee but it well yeah
that's true wait it's not like you guys
don't know well redlining is do it no oh
no it's how they blocked off they
blocked off certain neighborhoods which
were so incidentally predominantly black
neighborhood they were basically like
overnight these houses are not worth
very much yeah and then these houses are
worth a lot and you couldn't also get a
loan if you lived in yeah yeah and also
because school districts were based off
property taxes all the schools in that
area went to [ __ ] because they're not
getting as much money and so there's
just it's just another it's a systemic
racism and you couldn't go back then
they had it in the thing keep like your
communities white I mean pretty much
yeah doesn't the Starbucks and I know
this is not Starbucks related yeah this
is red line it's just a good March
opportunity I missed you I'll show you
what their merch looks like it looks
like this that's a cool shirt wait wait
that's like too much so that's like that
okay I'll wear it yeah I like how like I
like how they made her nails painted
yeah oh she's a lady protester or it
could be a man oh my god I swear yeah
nail polish yeah yeah that's good that's
better than I thought they're gonna come
out with one this is like Starbucks
and then they have black lives matter
but when they wear their there is
Starbucks
oh you see Starbucks oh yeah what's your
favorite drink at Starbucks
I'm more of a coffee bean guy why do you
like coffee bean what cuz the control
powder um no just because um I feel like
it'll get us involved in politics right
Jim they have cooler blacklivesmatter
t-shirts the design is way better the
tea leaf part is that Phil's coffee the
mint I want one great I'm not trying to
yeah they just opened one of the valley
right before quarantine yeah it's like a
bathing and then they boat out here too
I'm not a coffee person but she has me
like trained to like make her coffee
every night before going to bed she has
a thing that's like not like I set the
alarm
yeah so it like she told she taught me
how to do it and now like and she'll be
in bed and be like can you set the
coffee thing issue like whew did you
make my coffee I'm like coffee does she
drink wonderful is that right I thought
she had like her own roasted beans that
she buys from certain places no it's
just some Folgers okay yeah the best
part of waking up does she know that
because it sounds like she's drinking at
night that should be like a slow
innocent that's pretty good thanks I
just cope with it yeah yeah well what
the other day yeah yeah look together
I like the Kona coffee from Hawaii I
love that coffee is so good the coffee I
have at home is Kona coffee it is the
best you have to get a hundred percent
though if you get the blends yeah it's
not the same I tried it and it's like
their [ __ ] coffee that's like at the end
of it hundred percent Kona coffee though
alright all I heard was Corona coffee
cause I desire that or Hawaii is the
only place in the states or in the
States thanking grow their own coffee I
didn't know that mm-hmm why oh because
they have that very climate that the
weather the moment in Bali they have
this coffee it's like a special coffee
place yeah it's like the animals poop it
out and then they are supposed to be
like the best coffee ever I haven't
tried it I can't wait to eat some [ __ ]
coffee defecated
[Laughter]
seems like you took a [ __ ] right now
braid it like it came to me I was like
yeah spilled out cuz I was like is this
gonna make sense to the caffeinated Wow
I heard the splash is it hit the toilet
bowl I was alright because like it works
in so many ways it's like the same
amount of civil suit decaffeinated
defecate you can't repeat it you can't
do it again it was a one-time thing
that was awesome good night guys really
good though a nice way to end it a nice
way to end it
[Music]